[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans le 7-8
loisirs merci de nous retrouver pour ce
nouveau numéro dédié à vos idées sorties
tout de suite le sommaire de ce vendredi
15 décembre aux âmes sensibles ou
curieux la poésie s'ouvre au public à
versailles un cycle de lectures
rencontres avec les poètes contemporains
au coeur de la bibliothèque centrale
notre invité organisateurs de
l'événement nous en dira plus embarquez
pour une galaxie lointaine avec le
dernier opus de star wars les derniers
jedi et premiers fans eux se sont rués
sur les séances de la sortie mercredi 13
décembre leur avis sur ce huitième
épisode de la saga
un voyage non plus dans l'espace mais
dans le temps cette fois revivez les
danses de l'époque baroque au prisme
d'élan pour une plongée dans les xviiie
siècle à vivre en famille avec un
spectacle la panique
quelques festivités pour se réchauffer
ce samedi à magny les hameaux nouvelle
édition de parvis en fait rendez vous
incontournable de la ville pour s'amuser
avant noël spectacles de rue goûter
surprise et ateliers vous attendent le
père noël fera même une étape pour
rencontrer les participants
rendez vous sur le parvis de l'hôtel de
ville bertrand guillon le maire de la
commune nous dévoile le reste du
programme
il y aura aussi une découverte du golf
puisque à l'occasion de la ryder cup
l'année prochaine sur magny les hameaux
et saint quentin en yvelines
en fin de journée nous aurons un
spectacle de rue avec des ombrelles et
puis
nous aurons la visite du père noël bien
entendu qui viendra nous faire coucou
durant son voyage qui va l'emmener dans
toutes les maisons
donc il passera à 17 heures au niveau de
l'hôtel de ville
et puis on clôturera par un feu
d'artifice à noter également ce week end
le marché de noël de
voisins-le-bretonneux 34e édition
90 exposants seront présents au centre
sportif les pyramides ça commence samedi
16 décembre dès 10 heures des animations
musicales seront également proposés et
sans oublier ne mord pas qui célèbre la
aussi noël avant l'heure un marché de
noël installé place jacques debout mais
surtout une patinoire 200 m² accessible
pour tous jusqu'à dimanche 19h et il
fallait être dans une galaxie lointaine
très lointaine pour ne pas connaître le
jour de sortie du nouvel opus de star
wars pour ce huitième épisode les
derniers jedi les fans yvelinois se sont
déplacés en nombre dans les salles
obscures
michael et demi d'euros a recueilli
leurs impressions
et costume de dark vador de luke
skywalker les fans étaient au rendez
vous ce mercredi 13 décembre pour la
sortie de star wars lui dans ce cinéma
de saint quentin en yvelines
les amoureux de la saga n'ont pas hésité
à venir dès la première séance de la
journée à 9h45
toujours très important j'ai toujours
essayé de regarder les stars 11 déjà
ressenti et puis voilà sélection ça dure
au cinéma on a envie de connaître la
suite avait deux ans qu'on attend une
phrase de l'udc donc c'est important
d'être là aujourd'hui pour regarder tout
ça on en profite parce que comme ça ça
évite à près de se faire spoiler par les
amis qui ont eu l'occasion d'y aller
avant donc comme ça c'est moi qui veux
pouvoir disposer d une grosse pensée à
ceux qui travaillent au total le
multiplexe devrait attirer entre 4500 et
5000 personnes sur cette première
journée
on est pour l'instant sur les mêmes
tendances qui a deux ans on se
engouement dès ce matin dès les deux
premières séances ont fait salles sont
quasiment plein donc c'est un véritable
engouement pour star wars
après plus de 2h30 plongé dans une
galaxie lointaine retour sur terre pour
un premier verdict
franchement mille fois meilleur que le
précédent excitant l'action était là
il y avait les retournements aussi ya
d'actions iliad humour il ya pas mal du
bon je m'attendais pas autant d'humour
c'est bien c'est pas non plus trop fort
c'est chaud et one en scène les derniers
jedi devrait être en exploitation entre
deux et trois mois dans ce cinéma saint
quentinois
en france plus de 10,5 millions de
personnes s'étaient rendues au cinéma
pour voir l'épisode 7
il est temps
remplir
tout est dit
actuellement au cinéma et après avoir
bondi jouer les ninjas au parc à
trampoline au john parkes d'elancourt
une nouvelle section a été créée la
ninja warrior un nouveau parcours de 200
m² proposé aux visiteurs pour fêter le
premier anniversaire de la structure
pont de singe à nos échelles et sacs
accessible aux petits comme aux grands
aux débutants et aux confirmés chacun
pourra y trouver son bonheur
c'est des obstacles différents obstacles
le principe étant effectivement de l'est
de pouvoir les passer sans bien sûr
tomber sans mettre un pied dans les bac
à mousse
c'est une rapidité et une agilité tout
en ayant avec de la puissance quand même
un minimum de deux puissances c'était
une nouveauté encore une fois pour
remercier les gens les gens qui nous
sont fidèles
les gens qui continuent à venir on a
voulu effectivement se diversifier et
j'en profite
on en est là pour vous dire qu'il y aura
encore des nouveautés
je pense qu'en début d'année à noter que
le parquet reste ouvert pendant les
vacances de 10h à 21h il sera fermé
seulement le 25 décembre les horaires
modifiés pour le 24 et le 31 on va
parler poésie maintenant avec notre
invité
lamartine disait la poésie c'est
l'incarnation de ce que l'homme a de
plus intime dans le coeur averse
ajustement des poètes contemporains nous
ouvrent leur coeur dans le cadre de
lecture rencontre nous avons suivi la
première de ce site le mercredi 13
décembre
le poète anglais sir michael edwards a
lu des extraits de son oeuvre mais aussi
un poème de charles baudelaire
l'organisateur dj k n nous expliquer le
principe de ce projet et pendant que
jacqueline la coupe d'azur et kamiel de
soleil cool j'ai la bouche les nuages en
ou les sauts à tant de poésie ouvert ses
parties d'abord d'une résidence
d'écrivains dont j'ai la chance de
bénéficier c'est la région ile de france
qui propose des résidences un certain
nombre d'écrivains et donc j'ai déposé
un projet pour diffuser un peu de l'acca
poésie d'entente ou versailles et
peut-être alentours
autrement dit l'idée c'est de montrer
que la poésie à la fois ce qu'on connaît
en général mais ça peut rappeler d'un
nouveau moteur nerval mais qu'en 2017 la
poésie c'est aussi autre chose sont des
façons de parler la langue d'enrichir la
langue d'enrichir le sens une grande
diversité je pense que si on arrive à
aller vers le public et à
2 si les poètes reviennent eux même
parler au public lire leur poésie le
contact permettra de mieux faire
comprendre ce que c'est que la poésie en
2017 voire qu'il ya une continuité avec
la tradition et qu'il y a aussi des
façons de parler qui sont nouvelles qui
sont neuf et qui viennent enrichir en
quelque sorte notre imaginaire leurs
yeux tout la vie vinyle ans elle est
partie comme s'ils regardaient tour loin
reste levés au ciel on ne les voit
jamais gravé tranché rêveusement un
pesant qui ce sont des lectures
rencontres dans cette merveilleuse
bibliothèque centrale de versailles qu'à
chaque fois le principe de ces
rencontres à la bibliothèque centrale
c'est qu'un peu réduit vent vient
présenter son oeuvre dialoguer avec le
public et en même temps parle d'un grand
ancêtre qui l' a marqué qui a influencé
son oeuvre
ces rencontres elles sont faites pour
favoriser la rencontre entre des poètes
vivants et des lecteurs mais aussi pour
s'inscrire dans la tradition et montrer
que même si la poésie moderne découvre
ses propres chemins ouvre ses propres
chemins elle le fait sans ignorer
évidemment les chemins qui ont été
ouverts par les grands anciens
comptant pour les monts larmes ils sont
vraiment affreux pareil jean-marie qu'un
flamand pellicule qui relie mieux
s'amuser comme des somnambules d'ardents
on ne sait leur globe
j'espère que pour un dialogué avec les
lecteurs j'espère qu'on pourra les
rencontrer et j'espère qu'on pourra
répondre à leurs questions répondre à
leur entente à leurs attentes et leur
faire entendre la poésie ce dur
tranchant dans la lumière qui comme
l'ombre vivent dans la pelouse vers
obscur et rend les rouge à l'angle des
deux murs force de voter la poésie
souvent les lecteurs sont un peu
désarçonnés
c'est quelque chose avec lequel j'ai du
mal à m'y retrouve pas et c'est vrai
qu'on a des habitudes de lecture on est
amené à se précipiter va le sens à
essayer de comprendre immédiatement et
on est découragé quand on comprend pas
alors que la proche du texte poétique
c'est une approche différente une
approche peut-être plus proche
finalement de celle de la musique où il
faut d'abord essayer d'entendre ce
laisser aller se mettre à la disposition
de la langue ouvrir des oreilles tout
simplement je suis persuadé qu'il ya
beaucoup de gens qui ne connaissent pas
la poésie et qu'il apprécierait si la
connaissez mieux et je crois que le but
de ces séances de poésie ouverte c'est
d'ouvrir la poésie et de s'ouvrir à des
spectateurs à des auditeurs à des
lecteurs d'apport qui peuvent
probablement découvrir des univers qu'il
soupçonne peut-être et qui n'ont pas eu
l'occasion de fréquenter faute
d'opportunités
nous venons apporter en quelque sorte la
poésie aux oreilles de ceux qui voudront
bien venir nous rencontrer
et si vous dansiez comme au xviiie
siècle cette semaine le rendez vous des
juniors vous emmène en pleine période
baroque une période artistique
on prend notre machine à remonter le
temps qu'a mis parce que je vous propose
qu'on parle jusqu'au xviie siècle l'a
cette fois en 1600 c'est le début de la
période baroque une époque où de grands
noms ont marqué la culture comme jean
baptiste lully molière jean sébastien
bach deux siècles d'histoire à vivre aux
prises maëlan court puisque l'après midi
commence dès 15 heures et vous avez
rendez vous avec olivier j'aurai un
danseur professionnel
l'idée c'est de faire sous la forme d'un
bal une initiation à ce qu'on appelle la
belle danse donc quand on parle de la
belle danse et la danse qui danse à la
cour du roi à la fin du xviie siècle et
c'est une danse qui empruntait
d'opulence et les nobles à la cour et
qui empruntait beaucoup toutes les
danses populaires et régional de
l'époque mais en les rendant plus
élégante plus gracieuse voilà et c'était
vraiment très important dans la vie
sociale et artistique de l'époque un
début d'après midi pour découvrir la
bourre et la sarabande où la capote et
pour rendre le voyage dans le passé
encore plus réel le prisme vous invite à
venir déguisés et qui dit époque baroque
et dit surtout prince et un goûter dans
une race ce bal avant la dernière étape
un spectacle une pièce de théâtre aussi
tout droit venu du 17e siècle que
pourtant connaît bien je suis sûr qu'à
me que c'est votre dessin animé préféré
la belle au bois dormant
alors là c'est la fabrique à théâtre qui
va le présenter et si on connaît bien
nous le film de 1959 celui proposé aux
prises lui vient des comptes du temps
passé du recueil de ma mère l'oie dans
une mise en scène surprenante écouter on
est un éclairage à la bougie donc la
cible pompe sydney samedi aux prises
lure a aucun éclairage électrique
on est sur une gestuelle très
chorégraphique comme c'était le cas à
l'époque sur c'est une pièce en ancien
français avec des costumes d'époque
alors la psl commence à 17 heures pour
le bal c'est sur inscription à l'adresse
mail qui s'inscrit au bas de l'écran il
ya aussi un numéro de téléphone
mais attention pour pouvoir apprendre à
danser comme au xviiie siècle il faut
aussi assister au spectacle la belle au
bois dormant et donc à voir ces places
une après-midi historique à vivre dès
l'âge de 5 ans merci ma news on a
reparlé de ce rendez-vous au prix c'est
pour vous répondre dessins animés
préférés c'est plutôt le roi lion donc
j'attends une prochaine chronique dans
la sava grâce il existe un compte dans
les savanes qui vous y avoir
prochainement c'est prévu les études
choisir est maintenant terminé merci de
nous avoir suivi et un merci tout
particulier à pascal monteur émérite de
tv 78 postes depuis 1992 il nous quitte
pour de nouvelles aventures et c'est à
lui que l'on doit de nombreux montages
et aussi le son sur deux sur beaucoup de
nos émissions
alors merci à lui de nous avoir
accompagnés nous lui souhaitons le
meilleur pour la suite
quant à nous on se retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro et je
vous souhaite un excellent week end
m
oh